on de suite passer auit
soiravoc
de vontevenir les accusation Dean
Marchal contre Bruno mand cette histoire
qui est incroyable voilà depuis des
semaines et des jours on en parle avant
tout on regarde Yanis qui explique
pourquoi il a décidé de porter plainte
contre son ex professeur de danse merci
merci j'ai pris un moment en fait avant
de réaliser tout ce qui méta arrivé ça
prend des années et c'est vraiment 10
ans plus tard que c'est un peu venu et
que j'ai pu poter doit un peu sur bah en
fait remett pointer le doigt sur lui
j'avais déjà le l'envie d'en parler et
de faire quelque chose parce que surtout
j'ai toujours entendu parler d'histoire
qui continuaient à l'école de danse
n'importe quelle personne qui est dans
le milieu de la danse qui connaît Bruno
Vandelli c'est que il y a aucune
surprise aujourd'hui aucune de la merde
j'ai pas merci d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup à kaltou GI
merci merciou GI mercire l'avocate de de
Yanis et Nadia merci d'être avec nous la
maman Yanis merci beaucoup je sais que
ça doit être extrêmement compliqué pour
vous de venir témoigner euh et de venir
parler de ça mais merci à vous d'être
avec nous déjà avant qu'on écoute Nadia
et son thémignage qui est extrêmement
important pour nous j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un petit point avec Maître Gashi
la plainte de Yanis a été déposée ou pas
alors elle est déposée cette semaine
hein au parquet de grâce comme je l'ai
annoncé euh il y a beaucoup de choses à
dire euh on sera pas exhaustif
évidemment euh mais on voudrait livrer
le maximum d'informations au procureur
de la République donc elle sera déposée
euh soit demain mercredi soit jeudi
matin pour tout vous dire oui alors
c'est qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que vous
portez plainte pour viol agression
sexuelle et viol absolument viol aggravé
ah oui quand même d'accord agression
sexuelle et corruption de mineurs parce
qu'on on ait V eu l'avocat de Bruno
Vendell vendredi qui avait dit qu'il
n'avait reçu aucune aucune plainte bah
il risque pas de la recevoir parce que
euh quand on dépose une plainte on la
dépose au parquet au procureur de la
République alors l'avocat de la défense
en est nécessairement informé par les
actes d'enquête qui peuvent être
diligentés et lorsque il aura accès à la
procédure il aura accès à cette plainte
mais en l'état en tous les cas elle ne
sera pas entre les mains de la défense
alors Bruno Vandelli a porté plainte
contre Yanis Marchall pour quel motif
alors écoutez je suis au courant
d'accord c'est ce qu'il a dit voilà ben
je n'ai pas de plainte non plus entre
les mains oui je crois que c'est c'est
votre collier qui tap cont le désolé
contre le micro oui il faut juste que
vous mettiz dans voulez
queenève c'est juste ça tap contre le
micro excusez-moi merci merci non ben je
vais l'enlever merci vous inquiétez pas
on vous le vola pas ici hein j
Jean-Michel mer mais c'est tout pourquoi
juste maître pourquoi il y a plein de
questions moi je vous parle je vous
parle je vous dis les questions qui sont
posé pourquoi Yanis n'en a pas parlé
avant mais alors c'est c'est vrai que
c'est une question récurrente mais à la
fois la solution elle est assez évidente
en matière de de crime sexuel il est
extrêmement compliqué pour les victimes
de libérer la parole et c'est encore
plus compliqué lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
d'un enfant et c'est tellement vrai que
la loi elle-même prévoit que le délai de
prescription de l'action publique est
reporté à la majorité de la victime donc
c'est à partir des 18 ans que la jeune
victime
pourra déposer une plainte et elle aura
à partir de ces 18 ans 10 ou 20 ans en
fonction de la nature de l'infraction
voir 30 ans pour poursuivre l'auteur des
faits qu'elle dénonce donc en réalité
c'est un procédure un processus assez
classique chez les victimes de viol et
ce que je veux ajouter quand même c'est
que il y a certaines victimes qui tèsent
à jamais ce ce ce type de fait et qui
MEUR avec ce terrible secret donc il y a
un vrai chiffre noir comme on l'appelle
en en droit pénal sur cette questionl
alors
euh merci Nadia d'être avec nous merci
beaucoup
euh vous aujourd'hui déjà pourquoi vous
avez accepté et pourquoi vous avez
décidé de de de de réagir sur cette
affaire mais parce que hier j'ai regardé
enfin en fait en fait je regarde tout
oui je regarde tout je suis sa maman je
regarde tout bien sûr c'estm voilà mais
hier j'ai regardé euh je regardais votre
émission merci il y avait la jolie
blonde je sais pas votre nom Mo Kelly
Kelly qui a posé une question à au jeune
homme qui est venu témoigner oui qui est
le qui est Lionel te et oui voilà là et
qui lui a
demandé il posé la question et qui lui a
dit mais quel âge avait Yanis oui non
mais moi je viens sur le plateau déjà
pour préciser l'âge Yanis avait 13 ans
et demi 14 ans pas plus question donc
voilà
euh après bon ce ce jeune homme était
était très sympa il a témoigné en faveur
de Yanis mais après d'entendre des gens
qui font des supposition qui disent tout
n'importe quoi et quand j'entends qu'on
se permet de parler de moi sans savoir
là je dis stop bien sûr vous avez bien
raison dit stop euh parce
que à un moment donné il a dit euh il
est làin il est là oui bonsoir à un
moment donné vous avez dit euh
la maman de Yanis n'était pas d'accord
non la maman de Yanice
c'était quand on est normalement
constitué on ne peut pas être d'accord
c'est quasiment impossible donc le mot
d'accord il est inapproprié pour moi il
est complètement inapproprié moi quand
j'ai découvert le pot rose puisque j'ai
découvert ça sur le téléphone de mon
fils en
2004 fin juin 2004 ce sont des dat que
je ne peux pas oublier ce sont des faits
que je ne peux pas
oublier d'ailleurs je commençais à avoir
des
soupçons au sujet de ce monsieur Bruno
Vandelli qui ne ferait pas de mal à un
animal mais qui ferait du mal à des
enfants il peut porter plinte contre moi
pour diffamation j'en ai absolument rien
àer parce que tout ce que je dis ici
c'est la vérité tout ce que je dis ce
soir j'en ai j'ai toujours les preuves
je savais très bien que T tôt ou tard
cette histoire elle allait finir par
éclater pour tout vous dire je
l'espérais ah ça fait 20 ans que je
l'espère et quand j'ai entendu son
avocat dire Yannie ça fait un mois un
mois qui parle de ça un mois qui parle
de ça non ça fait 20 ans qu'on parle de
ça envie de lui répondre et quand
j'entends un avocat qui vient dénigrer
quelqu'un qui a subi ce que mon fils a
subi
bon ben alors euh non je me terraai plus
quoi c'est fini au contraire moi je suis
très très Fiè de du courage que mon fils
à en ce moment parce qu'il a des
nombreux il a de nombreux témoignages et
de nombreuses personnes qui lui envoient
des messages et qui lui demande de faire
quelque chose de par sa
notoriété malheureusement ça fonctionne
comme
ça parce que il y a il y a quand même eu
après moi il y a quand même eu pas mal
de plaintes pas mal de mains de mains
courantes qui n'ont pas abouti parce
qu'il faut dire aussi je sais pour
revenir à vous quand vous disiez la
maman était pas d'accord non j'étais
dans la panique la plus totale j'étais
dans l'horreur la plus totale j'ai tue
cette histoire à toute ma famille
personne n'est au courant d'ailleurs où
j'habite à valoris tout le monde doit
tomber de haut personne n'était au
courant j'ai caché cette histoire pour
protéger mon
enfant la première des choses que j'ai
faites quand j'ai découvert les messages
sur le le téléphone portable de mon
enfant c'est d'appeler Bruno Vandelli et
je peux pas oublier quand je l'ai eu au
téléphone il s'est mis à pleurer en me
disant en utilisant la pitié en me
disant que sa mère venait de sa
grand-mère venait de mourir sincèrement
j'en avais rien assiré hein voilà et
donc quand j'ai vu dans l'état où était
mon enfant parce que ce qu'il faut dire
ce qui a été le plus difficile pour moi
c'est de de ne pas pouvoir porter
plainte contre ce monsieur ouais parce
que j'avais en face de moi j'avais un
enfant qui était complètement
euh comment comment on dit euhise
dévasté non non il était quoi s il était
sousise il était sous une emprise totale
une emprise qui était effrayante de
Bruno Vandelli quand vous avez un enfant
de 13 ans qui se tort par terre et qui
vous supplie de pas porter plainte à
cette époque Bruno Vandelli était connu
il passait sur M6 popstar
oui il était connu donc moi je me disais
mon Dieu je vais pas mettre mon fils est
trop jeune pour aller pour se retrouver
devant les feu médiatique les médias
tout ça de par la notoriété de Bruno à
l'époque c'était extrêmement difficile
donc la seule solution j'ai quand même
été voir un avocat CAN et qui m'a dit
bah qu'il fallait porter plainte mais
vous aviez en face de vous un enfant qui
disait ben je je NIR et tout euh qui
était je vous dis sous son emprise mais
totale totale c'était comme si vous
aviez affaire à à quelqu'un qui est dans
une secte et qui qui et que et que vous
essayez de sortir de son gourou c'est
exactement pareil je sais même pas voir
pire je sais pas donc moi la seule
solution que j'ai trouvé c'est que bah
c'était d'éloigner mon enfant le va
envoyé aux États-Unis c'est ça donc j'ai
éloigné mon enfant j'ai appelé une amie
d'enfance qui vivait à Pensacola
marieclaude d'ailleurs qui est prête à
témoigner aujourd'hui sans aucun
problème qui s'est déplacé d'ailleurs
que je remercie qui a fait le voyage des
États-Unis jusqu'en France pour venir
prendre mon enfant et on l'a protégé
comme ça et il a été à l'école il a été
scolarisé à l'âge de 14 ans et j'ai les
preuves j'ai les documents j'ai les
attestation des écoles il était
scolarisé aux États-Unis à l'âge de 14
ans et demi
donc les faits ne se sont pas passés
quand il avait 16 ans là je réponds à
son avocat ce n'est pas une
mascarade la mascarade c'est son client
et la mascarade c'est que toutes les
personnes autour de Bruno Vanelli était
au courant ou toutes et dans ce milieul
tout le monde était au courant par
contre ce que vous avez dit hier de ce
qui s'est passé en 2005 à Paris je
n'étais pas au courant je couvert hier
parce que si je l'avais su qu'au retour
des États-Unis il y avait eu ça je peux
vous garantir que j'aurais pas fait de
cadeau ouais donc là vous avez bien dit
hier il fallait pas que la maman le
sache et exactement je l'ai appris
hier après je voudrais pas défendre mon
enfant parce que je suis pas toujours
d'accord avec Yanis moi tout t tous ces
réseaux sociaux cette façon de s'exposer
Instagram tout ça c'est pas du tout mon
truc
mais quand même ça fait déjà depuis à
peu près une quinzaine d'années qu'on en
parle avec Yanis où il veut porter
plainte où il veut pas où il veut où il
veut pas il veut il se
rétracte c'est reculé pour mieux sauter
quoi ça ça fait des années que c'est
comme ça et ça lui a provoqué des crises
de panique
voilà donc moi aujourd'hui bon même si
ça me ça
remue je suis dans un sal état parce que
je suis pas très bien de de de me
remémorer tout ce qui s'est passé mais
quelque part je savais très bien qu'un
jour ou l'autre ça allait
éclater et la vérité il faut qu'elle
éclate qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a
éclaté qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a
poussé Yanis à il a eu beaucoup de de de
de de de témoignag aussi d'autres
enfants d'accord et on subit la même
chose et qui qui qui qui dont les
parents ont d'ailleurs essayé de porter
plainte ou que ça ou que qui les
plaintes sont restées sans suite
d'ailleurs je demande à ses parents de
de de se rapprocher de moi puisque moi
Bruno Vandelli ne m'a jamais fait peur
d'ailleurs il le sait très bien hein et
je voudrais aussi j'en profite pour être
à la télé pour dire à Bruno que qu'il
'oublie pas le message que j'ai
découvert sur le téléphone de mon fils
I'm slave for you tout ça j'ai tout
gardé
Bruno
donc on nécrit pas des choses comme ça à
un enfant de 13 ans et demi
ça veut dire quoi déjà am je suis ton
esclave non ton esclave c'est ça donc
mais moi j'avais déjà c'est une chanson
de de Britney Spears ouais mais moi
j'avais déjà des doutes j'avais déjà des
doutes en
entre avril et mai 2004 puisqu'il était
insistant il voulait absolument que mon
enfant aille avec lui en stage de
formation si ma mémoire y bonne à mot et
là j'étais catégorique je disais non
hors de question
comme on avait déjà été avec son papa on
l'avait déjà accompagné dans un stage de
formation à mot donc je trouvais ça
bizarre qu'il voulait pas que son papa
et
moi soyons là et que il fallait qu'an
soit avec lui tout seul donc là c'était
catégorique je disais non et il dait
très très très très très insistant ouais
donc là ça m'a un peu mis la puce à
l'oreille et j'ai commencé à surveiller
le téléphone de mon gamin et je suis
tombée sur ce message voilà
alors donc c'est ça vous êtes tombé sur
ce message et là vous êtes dit a un mais
là je l'ai appelé tout de suite ouais il
vous a dit quoi il vous a dit quoi ben
je l'ai appelé je lui ai dit que j'avais
découvert le potau rose et surtout que
le le le nom le nom qui apparaît qui est
qui étaé sur le téléphone de mon fils
c'était pas le nom de Bruno Vandelli
c'était un prénom féminin ah ouais
d'accord donc il y avait tout qui était
calculé quoi c'est pas rien oui Kelly
non je voulais j'avais deux questions
c'est comment s'est terminé cette
histoire entre ces deux personnes est-ce
que c'est vous qui avez fait un peu plus
fort s'il vous plaît donc moi j'ai fait
partir mon filce que vous AZ fait oui
lapris se sont revu apparemment
États-Unis et Yanis a pratiquement fait
presque une année scolaire aux
États-Unis il a même il est même je l'ai
même fait
rentrer en école de danse là-bas parce
que la danse c'était tout pour cétait
FAM en fait est-ce qu'il a réussi de
lui-même à se ça a mis du temps mais moi
je quand quand Yanis a été scolarisé ici
à Paris à chez
ricodoms moi je croyais que je l'avais
complètement éloigné parce que Bruno
avait peur de moi et vous avez appris
hier qu'il c'était pas il pas
vouséé le verrait plus qu'
s'approcherait plus jamais de lui moi
j'avais croisé oui j'avais croisé Bruno
Velli à un spectacle d'un ami à moi qui
a une école de danse à Antibe qui
faisait ces gars là au Palais des
Congrès je peux vous garantir que quand
il m'a vu il s'est caché quoiou NAD il
vous a dit quoi au téléphone à ce
momentl quand vous avez décou pleuré il
m'a dit que sa grand-mère était morte
d'accord il essayé de jouer pas dit
rapport oui oui oui il a essayé de jouer
la
pié si si si il a essayé de jouer la
pitié avec moi mais ça pas fonctionné
hez dit je plus tu vois Yanis terminé ah
non non je lui ai pas dit ça je lui ai
dit que j'allais porter plainte ah ouais
d'accord ah oui non mais au début quand
j'ai découvert ça j'étais sur la plainte
j'étais sur aller déposer plainte mais
quand vous avez en face de vous ça je
vous je le je je je le souhaite à
personne je le souhaite vraiment à
personne quand vous voyez votre propre
enfant qui est sous l'emprise et je dis
bien sous l'emprise totale et c'est
effrayant de quelqu'un et vous voyez que
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez rien dire et
qui se menace de se suicider
euh il y a tout qui se mélange en fait à
ce moment-là il y a tout oui à l'époque
comment Yanis verbalisait sa relation
avec Bruno vendéif vous dites qu'il
était sous-emprise ça veut dire qu'il
disait que du positif à son égard ou
est-ce que parfois il y avit des chose
né disait que du positif à son égard
parce que Bruno lui faisait des
promesses aussi ouais professionnel oui
des promesses qu'il allait devenir grand
que il allait être son assistant que des
promesses oui oui oui il vous a jamais
dit qu'il y avait quelque chose de
problématique dans son comportement me
dit qu'il avait rien eu que me disait je
t'en supplie il s'est rien passé il
s'est rien passé avec lui il avait
vraiment peur et quand est-ce qu'il vous
a avoué que quelque chose sétait passé
mais moi je l'ai suis tout de suite qu'
s'était passé quelque chose sur qu' la
dame elle voyait dans son portable en
plus il était
jeune je chantais déjà ouais j'avais
déjà un pressentiment je sais pas si
c'est un pressentiment de maman maman ou
mais je sentais déjà qu'il fallait plus
qu'il y aille donc je commencé à emmener
mon fils moi-même au cours de danse et
je restais à l'école de danse évidment
on met un lien entre l'état de Yanis
depuis là 15 20 ans qui nous a raconté
déjà en plateau qu'il allait mal
certaines fois qui tombaé dans ses
travers qu'il avait des angoisses et ca
c'est un lien direct avec cette histoire
par rapport à ça et moi à plusieurs
reprises je l'ai incité à porter plainte
puisque je lui dis maintenant tu es
grand je Tu c'est bon on peut y aller
quoi mais c'est pareil il a il a une
notoriété aujourd'hui qui est que même
moi j'étais hésitante je me disais je
vais bousiller sa carrière h parce que
je le le truc c'est que vous vous avez
pas envie que votre fils de de la gloire
passe à à la victime Nadia juste vous
faites harceler depuis que votre fils a
annoncé publiquement qu'il allait
porortter plainte contre Bruno Vandelli
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit pardon
il paraît que vous faites harceler
depuis que vous depuis que votre fils a
annoncé publiquement qu'il allait porter
plainte contre Bruno Vandelli qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit pourquoi vous vous faites
harceler pourquoi on vous qui a dit que
je me faisais harcon nous a dit on nous
a dit que voilà il y avait des gens sur
les réseaux et cetera non je suis arrivé
dès que je suis arrivé de voyage j'ai eu
des messages sur le répandeur de de la
presse c'est pas et puis moi moi pour
moi c'est comme du harcèlement parce que
je suis pas quelqu'un qui qui qui qui
aime me mettre en avant je veux dire je
me je suis toujours derrière je veux pas
quoi je je faisais mes galas quand je
faisais mes galas de danse je venais
vraiment à la fin juste pour remercier
les profs mais j'aime bien rester
derrière quoi moi aujourd'hui je vous
dis très honnêtement c'est pas de guêé
de cœur que je suis sur votre plateau
quoi merci quand même d'être là voilà
mais je vous remercie mais merci merci
NAD merci qu'est-ce que vous auriez à
dire à à Bruno Vandelli ce soir ben à
Bruno Velli je je je qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je que je vais lui dire la
seule chose que je vais lui dire c'est
que Ben et ben c'est fini quoi c'est
fini l'histoire elle est terminée
aujourd'hui donc il vaut mieux qu'il
disent la vérité de toute façon s'il va
pas la dire moi j'ai des documents qui
vont qui vont faire en sorte que Ben la
vérité elle va finir par éclater et donc
c'est plus la peine qu'il raconte des
des des ballours à son avocat qui le
défend donc je comprends parce que c'est
son rôle c'est son r c'est son rôleez
votre avocate même elle est d'accord
c'est son rôle voilà mais bon maintenant
qu'il arrête quoi ça suffit merci merci
en tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci Maître Gashi merci Nadia d'avoir
été avec nous et vous avez été
incroyable en tout cas j'ai même pas
d'interview à faire vous vous parlez
tout seu vous n pas quoi j'ai même pas
d'interview à faire vous parlez toute
seule c'est magnifique merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec au MO western sur
C8
merci